[Applause]
great to have you guys here in my
kitchen now the secret success behind
simply thai is what heart and soul love
and care
now yum yum yup yum yum who came up with
that name
me you yes good good good you are my two
top thai restaurants make this
the best service of your entire life
yes chef
tonight simply tie from teddington and
yum yum from north london are competing
in the f-word kitchen
this is how they got here
earlier this year i asked you to log on
to the f-word website and nominate your
favorite local restaurants
the response has been absolutely
phenomenal
you told us about nearly 5 000 different
places you love to eat
40 years ago there was only one thai
restaurant in britain now there's one in
nearly every town we're a nation of thai
food fanatics
with the help of my team i set out to
whittle down your nominations
so you really rate the food yeah all
right great we were looking for the very
best it just gives you a very warm nice
comfortable feeling that you are in a
proper thai restaurant we're traveling
across the country really putting these
nominated restaurants under severe
scrutiny we went to the thai restaurants
you really care about
and after months of searching it was
clear that two of your thai favorites
were exceptional first up simply thai in
teddington
[Music]
with just 10 tables it's a tiny
restaurant run by a tiny chef but
petraeurapan has a hugely passionate
temperament uh table tree please table
three
table three
i just got a normal chef temperament i
possibly like gordon in the kitchen
firing tempered
petraea works ferociously hard seven
days a week sleeping just five hours a
night
play it now lola she makes every dish
almost single-handedly and each one has
to be absolutely flawless
where is the front
where
why would the plate please wipe the
plate if you are perfectionist you're
not going to let
anything go with even tiny tiny fold
petrae has dedicated her life to
creating perfect thai cuisine
she left her family in bangkok 37 years
ago and she's never married or had
children
all my time is here in the restaurant
the restaurant to me is my home is my
family
i was fascinated to finally meet this
culinary firecracker hello
how are you good afternoon sir good to
see you good to see you nice to see you
tell me about simply thai the secret
success is what i cooked a very good
food yes traditional thai food and i
cook with my love my care my passion
everything my heart i put into every
single dishes
amazing absolutely amazing
57 years of age on our own and cooks
every day
sleeps five hours a night if that's not
passion i don't know what it is
open plan kitchen
sees the dining room overseeing the
kitchen
and everything's just
about food food food
first up for me king prawn special
[Music]
well
and i also had to try patria's crispy
sea bass with jungle curry
those eyes scare me
honestly i feel like i've met the female
gordon ramsay from bangkok
it's incredibly crispy i mean really
crispy
amazing hot
spicy and everything won from typhoon
this lady shoots from the hip it's not a
traditional thai restaurant this lady is
pushing the boundaries out it's not a
selection of curry's i mean the menu's
authentic but
she homes in on the ingredients that's
the exciting thing i want the best and i
give the best
32 seats
yeah
is one thing
what i need you to do
is to start cooking for 50 because
you're through congratulations
okay
i need you to work at cooking for 50 not
32.
okay
congratulations
well done
really well done
that food was delicious really delicious
and if you cook that crispy sea bass
with your jungle green curry it's
amazing
really good
simply thai no that's accomplished thai
cooking um
yeah i mean a real thoroughbred i mean
my god that woman's passion she
sacrificed her life for that restaurant
it is really a dream come true i
wouldn't even want to win a jackpot i
wouldn't be excited is that
because it's my achievement my hard work
if you got strong determination you
would achieve what you want
so simply time is through and from your
nominations we found an opponent who
couldn't be more different
yum yum is on the high street in stoke
newington north london i knew the f-word
viewers loved it
this dedicated couple have worked for 17
years to build one of britain's biggest
thai restaurants
in contrast to simplitai's 10 tables yum
yum has nearly 90. we are very proud of
myself and my husband and all my team
muay is the head chef this is the
lemonglass one stem of it
when yum yum opened she only had two
people in the kitchen
now she has an army of staff 14 waiters
and 16 chefs catering for up to 500
customers every night
always full of people
great atmosphere customers say it's
brilliant at youtube as all the time so
that made me very proud
moy is a talented cook who's also built
up an amazing business i can't wait to
taste her thai cuisine
hello good to see you first name is
atti gordon good to see you look the
size of this place is huge
hello
where's moy
what's your signature dish what is it
your lamb curry yes i'm bored who's the
boss
[Music]
first up for me yum yum's most popular
starter the fish cakes
[Music]
the presentation is beautiful
we eat with our eyes before tasting
there is no secret ingredient
it's just my passion so that's why our
restaurants pack every night for my main
course lemon peanut butter curry lamb's
just falling off the bone
lovely so you've got the effect of the
bone marrow
the flavor it's ten times greater
and it's cooked so slow when that lamb
dish arrived with those potatoes and the
lamb cooked on the bone yeah it was
definitely there without a doubt proper
authentic thai cooking if i win the
competition you made me very proud this
country's been in love with thai food
for many years
i'm really sorry you're gonna have to
take a night off next week
congratulations because you are through
okay
congratulations well done thank you
forget big numbers nothing to do just
home in on 50 stunning portions of your
main course just cook from the heart
that's it that's that's important very
important cook on the head
[Music]
i feel very very excited and then i'll
do my best on that day
moy i mean she's amazing i mean there's
a level of
passion there from her and you can you
can taste it through the food
so from your nominations i've chosen two
extraordinary thai restaurants
will the f-word diners prefer patria's
obsessive attention to detail
or will it be seduced by the
sophistication of mighty yum yum
who will be crowned the f words queen of
thai cuisine
next on the menu as the thai teams go
head to head in the kitchen have i
finally met my match
too
what did you just say he's hungry she's
angry watch out don't make her angry
otherwise we're all screwed we're back
in london at the f word restaurants
tonight a cuisine that has exploded in
popularity in the uk
thai
with this irresistible combination of
fresh flavors exquisite presentation and
healthy ingredients it's no wonder that
thai food has become a hit with the
nation's food lovers
and thanks to your nominations and
months of searching we found the f
word's best two local thai restaurants
yum yum in north london
and simply thai in teddington
[Music]
25 portions of each is not a race chef
right on order focused everyone yum yum
two prawn fish cakes
thank you moy simply time six cod fish
cake yeah
yeah chef thank you though you scared me
then
hidden away in the london suburb of
teddington there's a tide restaurant so
authentic it wouldn't be out of place in
amongst the back streets of bangkok
[Music]
the russian success is a testament to
the die-hard dedication of 57 year old
kitchen dynamo petraea i've always got
very high ambition
i want to get the top of everything i do
simply time may only have 10 tables but
every single dish is cooked or finished
by petraeus don't do anything you
understand
temperament and obsessive quality
control are remarkable
i never never take a shortcut doesn't
matter how busy the restaurant
if things go smoothly i get bored
for simply thai's fish cakes petrol uses
only the finest freshest cod fillet
they're served with adjoined a
traditional thai cucumber salad
what's in here
what's in here um is cucumber shallots
chili and this
syrup it is sugar vinegar and why does
sweet salt work so well in thai cooking
what's the secret behind that the thai
knows how to use the sugar because
english cooking don't know how to use
they don't you don't have sugar in your
in your roast beef and your chipotle
definitely not no yeah do you think
these are better than moyes or mois is
better yes of course mine could be the
best
right moy yep where did the recipe come
from
from your mum yeah how long have you
been on the menu
for 17 years ready and how many portions
of the week do you sell we were five
five hundred
pieces very popular amazing
moya and her husband
has spent 17 years building up their
glamorous north london restaurant a
restaurant of this nature needs people
who appreciate the quality of what we
create
yum yum has had to open up a series of
new dining areas to make more room for
the ever-growing number of customers
i feel like i'm in thailand it's the
most probably the easiest way i can
explain it yum yum has 36 staff and can
handle up to 500 covers a night the
success of this restaurant is built on
fantastic service and a delicious dining
experience which keeps their customers
coming back again and again they will
ask me are you expanding the restaurant
i say no i want only one tyrant stone to
the best that is it that i want
moy makes her fish cakes using grey
featherback a fish that's highly prized
in thailand and will give moy's dish a
truly authentic thai flavor
would you ever cook these fish cakes in
a pan as opposed to fine they're always
deep-fried always deep-fried always do
you to try in the oven right quite nice
quite nice but too dry to dry yes we've
last stable two make these two as
exciting as the first two yep yep coming
soon everybody come in
go go go chef
two seconds complete the table first and
i'll send them all just in case yeah you
know why the food is too hot you already
said i don't want my food get cold yeah
i'm going now you happy with them yes
nice
okay table six please let's go
my simply ty i've only got 30 covers in
the dining room so this should be a walk
in the park for you to beat simply tight
tonight yeah i'll be able to share
myself
service please temple 14. right some
people say that food is a new religion
they may have a point
britain is home to almost 30 000 thai
people and in the heart of south west
london is europe's only purpose-built
thai temple where i'll be serving up a
very special meal
i love thai food i love cooking it and i
love eating it but this has to be the
most daunting task so far
this small and revered group of buddhist
monks live in the monastery attached to
the temple they spend most of their
waking hours meditating and studying
buddha's teachings forbid them to cook
so it's up to the local thai community
to offer the one meal the monks are
allowed to eat at 11 o'clock each day
helping me fulfill this honor and
privilege is chang executive chef of the
blue elephant one of london's top thai
restaurants
good morning good morning how are you
good morning how are you good to see you
thank you for coming to the blue
elephant a little bit tight in here
where have we gone chan
morning everybody
uh oh yeah yeah yeah pressure's on right
yeah so they're gonna be before 11
o'clock yeah are they fussy eaters no
they are really nice they're really kind
they ever send food back
no never
[Music]
the restaurant prepares the very best
dishes to offer to the monastery and
every dish has to be perfect
like these savory dumplings known as
money bags so that's a money bag
and that's it yeah sauce easy and simple
maybe you can try
these dumplings are usually served as a
starter pork and crab meat are wrapped
in a delicate bean curd pastry and the
tops are tied with thin strips of spring
onion now the shoe laces now it's uh the
next step
nice and tight very tight
and how do you call the money bag in
your language
chang's authentic money bags are
delicious but i want to show my take on
a classic thailand's national dish pad
thai
okay a quick pad thai
i fry shallots garlic and chilli with
salt and a little bit of sugar color on
the shallots
half the spring onions
this is a dish i love cooking at home
i'm using delicious king prawns and
adding some extras like chili and
tamarind paste
i'm so excited to be cooking for the
monks today yes never cooked for months
before
you know
those prawns smell amazing
my pad thyme is made sweet and sour with
fish sauce salt and sugar
turn up the gas
and the tamarind place
a beaten egg is cooked in the wok
and then added with the noodles and bean
sprouts to the sauce
i hope they're going to be happy with
this you know that i think the monk will
be happy
prawns and fresh coriander finish the
pad thai but what will chan think of my
quick and easy version of this classic
and then some peanuts around the outside
happy oh no but i had to test yeah
please oh you don't call pat i have to
take it first
what do you want to know from me ask me
how is it
oh no look at that face
this is not pad thai at all this is not
pancake
no but i have to be sweet sour and salty
i think that doesn't taste too bad
it's not perfect for you but not for me
you're a tough cookie i want to keep an
eye on the monks it goes down
traditionally chang isn't impressed but
more crucially what will the monks think
the food being offered today is brought
to the monastery to serve to the monks
bang on 11 o'clock
good morning
tam is a regular worshiper at the temple
where respect and etiquette are crucial
yeah of course
my path is separated into dishes and
joins the small portions of everyone's
food
every day all this food comes in right
donated
in this wonderful palace so this is one
tree
each tray is for each monk for each monk
look at all that food mr chang doesn't
like my pad thai it doesn't taste very
good apparently
i guess i can see from the canalis look
nice yeah exactly
the monks pray and chant before eating
this is a far cry from a service that
clara juice
now it's my turn but it's hard to tell
what they make of it because if you
offer food you're forbidden to talk to
the monks whilst they're eating
i knew it was going to be you know
respectful and you know brilliantly done
but it's very serious very serious it's
always like this always
well always
to find out how well the pad thai went
down i spy on the monks to see if
they're enjoying it
how can you say my bad dies yet look
come on for me
but maybe the man like that tastes but
they don't like it
look at that
it's the most eaten bowl
my pad thai seemed to go down well but i
couldn't resist breaking the protocol by
asking the monks about the food
one very simple question did you enjoy
the pad thai yes
[Laughter]
this experience takes respect for food
to a completely different level
it's humbling and a fascinating insight
into thai buddhist tradition
that was an amazing experience and it
was so nice to see such traditional thai
culture here in the middle of wimbledon
as for being a monk and eating my last
meal at 11 o'clock in the morning nah
thanks but no thanks
[Music]
right last table yeah moy table two
please yes
thank you
good well done
that's it
very good
fish cakes were amazing uh the sauce
like a sweet sausage sauce and
complimented it really well the fish
cakes were a little bit rubbery but the
flavors that and the ingredients that
went into them were really good welcome
therefore really good to see you thank
you how are you absolutely yeah nervous
yeah yeah how do you think your dear
lady is doing in there
you know she is the kind of person that
would would
hit it while at the spot i'm very
confident that so you can handle
pressure brilliantly absolutely and what
it means for you
to leave here this evening as your
victory you know for our area stoke
newington it's very important for us
i love the presentation all laid out
beautifully beautiful little dressing
not your usual sweet chili sauce dumped
on the edge of the plate it was too much
spice in
the cod cakes and in the end i didn't
wasn't able to recognise what else was
in there welcome to the work really nice
to see you oh thank you you worked with
pottery a lot yes yes does she share in
front of the customers sometimes she
just get out from the restaurant this is
my restaurant if the some customer a bit
rude or complained to her yeah and she
throws them out yeah now what would it
mean for her tonight to leave the f-word
restaurant as a winner
she hopes a lot she will get the
the winner i think
now
yum yums are made with a great feather
back from prawns basically a thai
freshwater fish
mmm
it's rather spongy
feel that little texture of a sort of
sponge when you press it with a fork
and simply tie again
quite
an interesting dressing
love the color
texture-wise
that's delicious
it's less spongy
and sort of more robust
both very delicious give me a tough one
to call if it was me i'd have to go for
a simply thai
while the rest of the diners enjoy yum
yum and simply thai's fish cakes here's
my take on this classic thai dish
clay fish cakes fragrant delicate and
packed full of flavour first off start
prepping the fish fillets of coli
prawns
red curry paste
sugar
fish sauce
salt
[Music]
eggs
kaffir lime leaf
coriander
lid on
pulse
french beans
shape just flatten it down a little bit
chill
cucumber relish
chopped cucumber shallot chili lime
dressing coriander and mint
hot
pan vegetable
fried
they smell delicious
drain
[Applause]
[Music]
thai fish cakes with cucumber relish
done
so all the diners have finished their
starters and the results are in now they
are tough customers out there how well
do you think you did i'm happy very very
happy out of 25 customers how many do
you think are happy to pay for that
oh
all
wow
i love that
huh
moy yeah how many do you think out of 25
and have a different five hours
25 out of 25. what's with the conflicts
between you guys it's amazing okay let's
find out the results jb
thank you
let's start off with simply thai yeah
the amount of customers they're happy to
pay for your delicious fish cakes out of
25 is
21 out of 25 that's amazing
that is amazing
that's very good
huh
what did they like the four guests
slightly overcooked slightly overcooked
yeah really yeah couldn't taste as well
the fish okay don't show those four
customers to patro she'll kick them out
okay very good start are you happy thank
you yeah
are you happy very happy good i'm glad
you're happy so you should be no moy
your heart is pounding okay let's see
the number of customers out of 25
willing to pay
for yum yum's fish cakes
is
22 out of 25 well done
well done
that is
incredible really well done
22 out of 25.
both fantastic scores yum yum you're now
one point in the lead
clear down and get ready for the main
courses they could all change yes on
this main course well done now 50
portions each you can do this good luck
there's only one point in it yes yes
okay let's go right simply time for pork
curry let's go
thank you yum yum for chicken curry no
one's answering me anna's six thank you
ladies okay
now both thresholds are cooking the main
course first up is simply thai
petraeus
is an incredible driving force behind
simply thai and teddington
absolutely love her food i've been
coming since i was
10 i think lots of the people here are
very faithful regulars patria's amazing
work ethic is matched only by her
passion for the food she serves every
dishes on the menu is my favorite
one sweet spicy pork please
simply thai signature dish tonight is
spicy sweet pork
to make a paste petraea finely cuts
lemongrass chops galangal similar to
ginger but it's much more subtle
peels and slices the skin of a thai lime
garlic coriander root and thai shallots
the smell the aroma is much stronger
than the continental shallots next she
adds red chili
black pepper and crispy pork fat and
grinds to a fine paste in a petal and
water
i learned to make this recipe with my
arms this is what very little must be
about 13 or 14 years old i had to
sit on the floor and my hand that time
was so small and this is big
and it's really a hard work for a little
girl
she fries the pork loin and puts aside
in a saucepan she fries off the paste
adds coconut cream and the fried pork
loin
next she adds steamed pork belly palm
sugar white sugar some fish sauce and
chopped fine green beans
she serves a deep-fried salty duck egg
and a salad with sweet thai dressing
service
please
spicy sweet pork served
[Music]
now tell me about the recipe what you've
got about it it's quite a complex very
very very complex and hard working it
took me
six hours last night just to make the
curry paste because we have to use pesto
and mortar well i got a neighbor came
round and look at the door
maybe not yeah knock at the door what
are you doing why are you banging i've
never heard it before you dancing
something was it in the middle of the
night
no 10 o'clock 10 o'clock in the evening
in the evening did you throw them out
yes it did yeah good now moy yep you're
one point in the lead are you feeling
confident yeah chef
head chef moy has been serving up a
flavor of thailand to yum yum in north
london for almost 20 years i've been to
thailand quite a few times and it's most
probably the nearest i would get to it
absolutely fantastic
from starters right through to dessert
absolutely amazing
food has always been a huge part of
moy's life and she was trained to cook
the traditional thai way
in in thailand yeah thai girl in a
family must go to the kitchen
and learn how to cook
yum yum signature dish tonight is red
chicken curry with plantain
moist starts by peeling and slicing
green plantain
[Music]
she peels a green papaya and slices it
in thailand we have this in our backyard
so we grew up with this
and easy to get
and you don't have to buy it
next for the red curry paste
she cuts lemongrass finely
chops galangal
the rind of a thai lime
a coriander stem
and crushes garlic oh
it's going away
then she adds to seeded red chilies and
blends
[Music]
she fry the red curry paste in a hot wok
for 10 minutes she adds coconut cream
fish sauce sugar chopped chicken the
plantain and papaya
she then cooks it for five minutes
finally moyad's red and green chilies
and thai sweet basil
[Music]
red chicken curry with plantain
served
[Music]
now moy you're currently in the lead
yeah what do it mean for you to win
tonight we're happy very happy what
would you do for the restaurant
party party
party
and what other thai should you think
you're good in london i don't know
wow
wow wow wow what makes yours stand apart
i'm quite confident that my food is good
right
patra
you ever been to nam the mission star
thai restaurant
several times do you enjoy it
yes i did
fantastic food yeah and more have you
ever been to naam no i haven't been
there no never heard of it i've heard of
it yes do you think you'll be the second
child to get a mission of style yes it
will be soon soon soon i like that
confidence pattern yes chef what does
your husband think about your food
i haven't got one and i don't need one
no i'm capable of looking after myself
i'm sure you are but would you like me
to introduce you to a nice young french
voice no thank you
no no thank you okay no sorry jb patrick
said no she wants someone a little bit
younger you're too big
honestly she's getting out what's the
matter
what did you just say
she's angry yeah watch out don't make
her angry otherwise we're all screwed
are you demanding with men as much as
you are in your kitchen
no compromise no compromise yep
savage please
patriarchy
seriously when was your last day off
uh last
sunday last easter sunday yes oh my god
so you don't take sunday monday off with
your days off no
i can't afford it you're amazing you are
an iron lady i'm determined well done
bloody good job thank you spicy sweet
that's a good lie i like that
the chicken was very well cooked it was
well presented because the rice was out
of the bowl which was a lot more easy to
consume as well it had the classic kind
of thai taste to it but the only thing
that really didn't work for me was the
plantain it was a little bit hard a
little bit bland
the port was cooked very well it's very
tender nicely thinly sliced the actual
curry itself was quite greasy and a lot
of the meat it was quite fatty and i
found the rice to be a bit cold so i was
a bit unhappy with this course
right
simply ties pork curry very authentic
put caulk twice slow roasted
and then a loin of pork sauteed
finished
mmm
flavor's amazing
texture delicious not too hot but a real
nice depth of flavor this is a very
authentic pork curry
absolutely phenomenal yum yums
that's the kind of color you're
expecting a chicken curry
there's such a difference a huge
contrast simply thai
tastes and looks authentic
yum yum comes across mainstream and
not that exciting i would imagine that
the diners would prefer the authenticity
of simply thai
with only one point between the teams it
couldn't be tighter okay let's find out
the results uh john baptist please okay
let's go simply tie first yeah
so bearing in mind but they are a tough
tough bunch of diners this evening
the number of customers are happy to pay
out of 50
is
wow
39 out of 50. well done
huh
that's really good
pretty good indeed
that's a great score
39 uh jb feedback they found the little
bit too fatty they found the meat a
little bit too fatty would you like to
throw out the 11 people they're not
going to pay for it um
no no no okay because they're still good
they have to still decide
exactly what well done 39.50 pretty good
okay yum yum the number of diners that
are happy to pay for your chicken curry
yeah
is
wow
23.
that's a bit of a shock okay jv the main
problem was too spicy two spices spicy
they found a portion as well not
balanced uh somewhere big somewhere
smaller damn
it's not over yet you can pull this back
it has happened before
yeah clear down let's go for the dessert
right damn yeah there's a shop
now time for the recipe challenge we've
got everything here restaurants yes
cameraman yes chef yes celebrities yes
ingredients yes let's [ __ ] do it
it's good to see you oh we don't need
this now what are you cooking i'm going
to do a trifle it is so simple to do
because you know you're not i can see
you know faffing around with eggs and
yolks and vanilla pods and all that sort
of stuff i mean literally just sponge
fingers lemon curd and liqueur and
you're off right so you're making trifle
okay i'm making a trifle i'm making my
version of a trifle now shouldn't be
doing the custard first are you doing
the sponge first uh no doing the sponge
for uh actually that's a good point it's
quicker
probably if i did the cream first how
does this work
normally if you were doing it for six
people yes you would need half a liter
of double cream just over 100 grams 120
grams of caster sugar that is quite a
lot of sugar trifles not exactly cutting
edge is it something you remember from
your childhood uh yeah well childhood
with a scottish childhood like yours
then when we were children i mean it was
about getting as much cholesterol as you
could in two kids until they died wasn't
it
it was massive it was meat pies it was
haggis slice cream so roy's doing his
version of his trifle i'm gonna do
exactly the same this time i'm gonna use
panettone first i'm gonna make a really
nice delicious custard now this is the
fun part this is the quantum you
sprinkle a little bit over there if i
was doing keith floyd a little bit over
there and quite a lot in here
[ __ ] me that's gonna kick right okay
very very good that's all wonderful
don't forget keith floyd very very sadly
miss he was a man who invented all that
thing that gordon is so good at which is
of course swearing on television right
okay uh how are we doing right where's
the cream going round round round you
see this is the thing your voice is hard
to do
because you've lost the scottish accent
do you think it's that difficult to do
yeah you can get a bit there's a little
bit of birmingham in there but i don't i
just you know i kind of listened to you
and i've tried i've studied you i've
done you in shows what works is the
makeup yeah is that i mean it takes an
hour and a half
the scars an hour and a half it took how
do you do that every morning yes
your forehead looks like mine already
come on i do i know
we
uh i'm going to put some lemon juice
into this to make some lemon custard
okay how old are you when you first
started doing impressions uh about uh
eight or nine i used to watch my yard a
lot remember mike yard yeah and he was
if he was the first person to do bob
mann castle like
all that he used to love me bob and
david attenborough all of those and
prince charles
in front of your parents reggie yeah
yeah yeah
there's too many impressions of people
alive uh get off yes sir we have david
blanket
chef with pie but he was always so
aggressive david was uh don't
don't pat the doggy love your [ __ ]
head off
no today i'll be launching daft
legislation no sorry i'll read that
again
draft legislation how long does it take
you you perfected blair bush well that
took me about yeah 12 years i think
george bush we miss you know he went it
was the end of an error so now we have
obama
obama can you do it he's cool
he's authoritative and um just want to
say
he speaks
slowly
if there is anyone out there who still
doubts
we haven't got time to do the whole
thing we'd have never can you do an
impression of obama
come on
you're so serious tonight i'm doing
now the custard's thickened
great a touch of the orange zest in
there that makes it nice and light
fragrant less rich
the panettone
slice nice and thinly
not too thick
and then cut the slices in half and
spread
with a little thick cut marmalade and
then from there
slice that down into cubes a little
touch of ground manure
on top
so that really nice rich
flavor running through and then from
there can i watch you because my recipe
means i've got loads of time
from there
thing is roy i'm gonna beat you this is
not a race it's about perfection you
know how competitive i am huh
now right there you have the features
set
and then blind tasteful pick a winner
feeling confident uh yes yeah i think
what's that i hope that is the fridge
isn't it yeah it's definitely the best
i've just put it in the dishwasher
in the dishwasher cycle to 25 minutes
fantastic lovely clean taste
now welcome back to the f word time for
the results the recipe challenge ready
yes absolutely excited yes very now what
is that you put on top of that were they
uh this is crystallized violets violet
petals so you've got silver balls
uh i have on the trifold on top of the
trifle
i'm finishing my cream with a bit of
lemon zest just to give that a little
bit of a wake up and then grating some
chocolate on there chocolate orange
lemon
don't worry
all right ready mine doesn't look as
flash as yours yeah yeah one for kids
and one for adults oh yeah that is no
right jb
good
no no put your fingers in there don't
drop those do smaller
[Music]
i actually think that is really nice the
lemon flavor was really nice
it's very different actually completely
different this is very vanillary
it's quite sweet actually as well okay
results uh right jibby oh no he's got
that french smoke what do they think of
both the trifles they really like both
of them but the silver balls
yeah they really like it what were the
scores
um five to nine
five nil hold on that is pretty yeah
that's fantastic yeah come on don't do
this to me i hate it when you've got
that smirk on your face no look
watch these little hands where they're
gonna wave where are they going
triumphal humiliation yeah come on who
yes
fantastic
excellent
now back to the competition and it's
time for dessert both thai brigades will
be cooking my recipe
mango lime and coconut rice pudding an
asian twist on a traditional rice
pudding first off rice into the pan
400 milliliters of coconut milk 80 grams
of caster sugar
vanilla pod
what the vanilla pod does to the rice it
helps to really perfume and make it
really nice and fragrant
simmer for 20 minutes
hot pan desiccated coconut
toasting the coconut really helps to
bring out that nice nutty flavor
when the rice is tender add 150
milliliters of double cream the toasted
coconut
and chopped mango
fold it in
[Music]
top with mango pistachio
toasted coconut finish the rice with a
little grating fresh lime beautiful
thai mango lime and coconut rice pudding
done
uh
yeah this is the most important course
for you of the night you can pull this
one back yes yep yep yeah good i'll do
my best in here
there's only 25 more plates each yes it
got to be perfect yeah they have to be
perfect and one of you is going to come
out as the winner
if simply tie win tonight it will mean
everything to patria
i would be so excited it's just like a
dream comes true
and for yum yum victory means the
massive restaurant will be fully booked
for months to come oh my local
customers
they'll be very proud of yum yum thai
restaurant
now please don't give up
i know you're behind but you can pull
this back i'm not worried because i'm
not worried uh patra what kind of
desserts do you have that's simply thai
coconut cream bullet and so you've got a
recipe
but i
i change the milk to coconut oil so it's
my recipe for creme brulee but you put
coconut in there yeah
careful montana if you keep on pasting
it it's going to break it up
and it'll end up in the bowl
yeah like wallpaper paste
still paste it
so this is interesting unfortunately moy
has dropped her confidence and sort of
become very very quiet on the other hand
petra has sort of raised the bar and she
wants to really make sure this rice
pudding is absolutely perfect and she's
having fun with it as well
oh jesus we've been drinking champagne i
can't believe you're this happy you
haven't won yet
two portions of sugar in one pan
oh no i haven't done that sir
not yet
montana yeah the rice is ready so if it
sits here longer it's over cooked yeah
moy's doing everything try to get a
system going you put the rice in you put
the potatoes on you put the mango on you
put the lime on okay yep four
my dessert was absolutely lovely um 10
out of 10. absolutely delicious i think
it's amazing i think yeah with the the
mango the fresh mango as well yeah
we're happy
i thought the rice pudding was delicious
i thought the mango was perfect the
coconut you could really taste it
consistency of the mango and the lime
you know amazing there we go
all finished
right desserts simple fragrant thai rice
pudding my recipe but have they done it
um yum yum nice the unfortunate thing is
the rice is slightly pasty a little bit
overcooked
simply thai
rice is perfectly cooked
that is delicious
yeah i like that
time to find out who's going to be
crowned the f word's best local thai
restaurant
okay time for the results uh jb please
so thank you
let's start off with
yum yum okay okay
the amount
of customers
that are happy to pay for dessert out of
25
is
17 out of 25. that's amazing
that is amazing
well done and you didn't give up well
done thank you really good okay simply
time
the number of customers that are happy
to pay for your dessert out of 25
is
damn
that means in total you have 82 out of
congratulations really really well done
montana well done i'm enjoying it now do
me a big favor yes
get out of here and get yourself a big
drink congratulations ladies and
gentlemen
i enjoyed it very much and on top of
that i got this that proof isn't it that
um you know if you put your heart and
soul into everything you work you're
gonna you can achieve